foreign
's going to start us off in Denver
Colorado this hour hey Braden what's up
hey guys well um long time listener and
thank you for taking my call my pleasure
can we help my question is
um
it's a very long story but um basically
my mom has no money
um and she's 62 and I'm wondering how I
can protect myself or prepare to I guess
just help her in retirement so that's it
and I'll let you guys maybe ask the
questions okay financially and legally
you don't have anything to protect
yourself from
so there's if she has debt it doesn't
leap over to you upon her death it just
goes away with her so that there's no
issue there but the only issues then it
sounds like you're wanting to help her
in this situation and and then that's a
whole nother barrel of Fish Hooks right
yeah yeah basically I feel like I'm
cornered a little bit in the sense of
I either take relatively full
responsibility of taking care of her or
she she kind of ends up on the street is
what I feel like I'm I'm facing
what happened to your dad
um he was tired of supporting her they
got in a divorce about five years ago
and um she was pretty dependent on
depression and anxiety pills and
basically went numb
um and she's been numb for about seven
years and I would say she's addicted I'm
not sure if that's a if that's a real
thing or not yeah it can basically okay
so basically um she's really dependent
on those and um is very very depressed
and basically my dad said I can't
support her lifestyle because because
legally he was supposed to be doing that
and so he fled the country and
um he's I don't know I think he's in
Thailand right now basically
it was a hard decision for him to make
but he said
um hey I love you but I've got to go
because the court system's making me
give her money and I can't I can't
continue to let her do that to herself
so are we talking about uh alimony
yeah basically my when it all happened
my brother was 16. he's 18 now
yeah well well you know and I don't know
exactly what it is Dave who took care of
your brother who took care of your
brother
where my mom was your dad didn't feel an
obligation take care of his kid
no well well my brother is addicted to
marijuana and what my dad was doing was
he was giving them thousands of dollars
a month and and realized that he was
supporting two drug addicts and my
brother was stealing money from my mom
to buy us marijuana and he just said I
can't I can't see is he out of her house
now
yes he he left he dropped out of high
school and he's living with his
girlfriend and his their family
apparently what's your setup another
book are you married how old are you
yeah
um 29 married
um followed you guys a lot that free
baby steps four five and six awesome um
just had our first baby
um and we live in Wyoming household
income
about 100 120. okay
Dave I've got an opinion but you've seen
this way more than me you dive in
brother my because I gotta I got a
feeling I'm gonna be right on your
coattails Brayden I here's the thing I I
it's easy for me to sit up here and say
I wouldn't do anything like you don't
have to do this and she gets to choose
whatever
I also know like my mom is in her 70s I
I wouldn't be able to sleep at night if
I didn't sit down and at least say
here's the best way I can love you and
here's the skin in the game you've got
to have to make this thing happen
and so I I a couple of things at play
here one you've got to sit down with
your wife and decide as a couple what is
how far are we willing to go is that
move mom in is that send some money
somewhere like what how far and how able
are we to go and borrowing money and
making this whole thing mess bigger for
your for your generationally is not an
option right so how can we what are we
willing to do and if nothing is on the
table then nothing's on the table but
y'all need to have that conversation
together the second thing is
you know this that um
whatever narrative you have from your
dad from your mom it's it's way more
complex and way more of a mess than that
and so I think you need to keep all eyes
moving forward not trying to untangle
the past it's too messy you don't know
all the things
um it sounds like one of those if your
dad's willing to walk out on your
brother willing to walk out on his
responsibilities then it may be one of
those situations that her over the years
her addiction was uh to cover up a whole
bunch of other mess in the house all
that to say is this
you get to say hey Mom
here's what here's what um I'm going to
require of you to participate in some
sort of support or help if you choose to
do that and the hardest thing in the
world I can't think of another harder
thing than to watch someone you love
make choices not accept care not accept
responsibility not accept help and
you watch them fade away it's it's one
of the it's one of the most difficult
challenge I think it's the most
difficult thing we can do is to watch
loved ones fade away
Braden I had a good friend who
drank himself to death he drank until he
died
and I killed him his liver went bad and
he kept drinking the doctor said you got
three months to live if you quit
drinking and a month later he was gone
because he didn't
um and I sat with him I'm like dude you
know you might as well just put a gun to
your head it's the exact same thing put
the bottle to your head I mean it's just
the same thing and I there's nothing I
can do
nothing there's no word to say I mean
he's going to do what he was going to do
I couldn't like stop him and like John
said it just tears the heart out of your
chest somebody you love
you know running running the car in the
ditch and you're sitting here going hey
just turn you know just keep it in the
road you know and um it's very very
difficult to watch so I the first thing
you have to do is you have to protect
your wife and your child and your future
that's your primary obligation beyond
your any obligation you could have to
your mom anything you do for your mom
that interferes with your wife your home
and your child and your the future of
your family is an improper level of care
no matter what no matter what she does
okay
she does not
get the right with the life she has
lived to interfere with your future to
the point that it just that it destroys
your child's future you have a baby that
you are the father of that's your
primary goal having said that then if
you want to love her well then you need
to require some things of her that are
good for her she needs to be seeing her
therapist she needs to be monitoring her
meds she needs to be she's going to read
she needs to go to rehab she needs to
get a job she needs to be on a budget
that you look over her shoulder and make
sure she's managing the money that she
has well she can get on Social Security
and it'll go a long way towards keeping
her from being hungry do not give her
cash give her groceries pay her rent
directly but only if she's doing steps
that are going to you know that's going
to facilitate her having a Dignity of
agency again standing on her own two
feet again I'm sorry man I hate that for
you man